>> Okay, Michael, so you seemed like you knew what you were doing
so I thought I would verify that by giving you a very easy quiz.
>> This doesn't look so easy.
>> It is easy, so here's the quiz. To help you I've written up both the
Bellmans equation and the update that we would give to utilities. I neglected
to write the little hats and everything because I just don't think you need that
but these are the two equations that you need to be able to think about.
This is just what we've written up before. And I've written down the
grid world we've been playing with the entire time. And I want you to
figure out how value iteration would work from the first iteration and the
second iteration for this particular state here that I marked with an X, okay?
>> Okay.
>> Alright, and there are a little more information you
need to go. Gamma in this case is going to be
equal to one half. Mainly because it's easy to do
the math if you do it that way. The rewards,
just to remind you, for all of the states except for the two goal
or absorbing states is going to be minus
0.04. And my initial arbitrary utilities for
all of the states, is going to be 0, except in the two absorbing
states where I already know the utilities are 1 and minus 1 respectively, Okay?
>> Okay.
>> You got all that?
>> I think so.
>> You sure?
>> [LAUGH] I feel confident
that I'm going to slip up, but Okay, yeah, I think I can take a stab at this.
>> Alright, so gamma's one half, rewards are minus 0.04, arbitrary
starting utilities at times 0 is 0, except here at the absorbing
states. Tell me how the utility here will evolve after one step,
or one iteration, and two steps, or two iterations. Okay then, go.